we begin tonight hannity watch on the
extreme
radical left it's really important as we
begin you ask yourself some questions
do you want the government to have more
control over your daily life
or less do you want the government to
take more of your hard-earned money
or less do you want the government to be
more involved in your business
or less involved you want the government
to have more control
or total control of your health care or
less
and do you believe the government has a
duty to protect your borders
from let's see heroin fentanyl
traffickers human traffickers cartels
gangs
and the criminal element not the good
people that want a better life
that come to our border and access our
country illegally
because now it is perfectly clear the
lines have been drawn
nearly every single elected democrat
almost
all of those running to challenge
president trump in 2020
they want more and more total control of
your life
they don't trust you the american people
remember they think
we are irredeemable deplorables that we
cling to our god our guns our bibles and
religion
and we're those smelly walmart people
now they want control of
everything it's actually beyond radical
and extreme
it's scary it's a failed ideology it's
been tried over and over
it creates dependency they make promises
that never come true it never comes
close to what they promised and even
worse
the people that are promising all of
this great stuff
keep your doctor care save money they
really only want power
for themselves now socialist
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
and far-left senator ed markey are now
set to unveil what they call their
so-called green new deal legislation
now this bill will dictate how you heat
your home
cook your meals and even how you commute
to work in fact according to
previous proposals ocasio-cortez wants
this country by the way we just became
the number one producer
of oil on the planet surpassing saudi
arabia russia
all fuel and gas fossil fuels we will
not have them in 10 years
that's not just socialism that's
authoritarianism
and she literally wants to nationalize
enormous
profitable private industry kill it off
completely
that means all the millions of
high-paying career jobs in the
oil and gas and energy sector guess what
gone it will force every american to pay
drastically more
expensive for all forms of energy
the lifeblood of our economy but
according to ocasio-cortez
if the federal government doesn't take
dramatic authoritarian action
the world is going to end in 12 years
well
that only gives us two years of our plan
why bother anyway she actually thinks
the future of humanity is at risk
because
of energy independence um we have more
energy we can help our allies our
friends
create millions of high-paying jobs for
americans and we've tried your way
before
doesn't work take a look i
do not think that for the future of
humanity
and for our
country to continue to prosper
that we cannot have another presidential
cycle where climate change is not being
asked
about at almost every debate got only 12
years left
actually the future of humanity faces
far more risks
from the authoritarian far-left
socialists
look at venezuela oh they have a lot of
energy
but they don't have any money or food
and poverty is rampant
let's see cuba they didn't do too well
there either former soviet
union oh communist china how's that
working out
look at what life is like in literally
any country that nationalizes private
industry
and imposes strict government controls
over private businesses and
that's not stopping democratic
presidential hopefuls like oh elizabeth
warren
from declaring the capitalism can be
good but only if the government has more
control
and only if she and her fellow democrats
have a chance to impose even more
rules and regulations take a look
let's be really clear capitalism without
rules
is theft encouraging companies
to build their business models on
cheating people that's not capitalism
that's not competition in the
marketplace
that's not producing consumer surplus
so what i believe is capitalism with
serious rules and that means rules
where everybody gets chance to play
excuse me
a lot of people risk a lot of money to
start businesses
no hope necessarily they'll succeed they
create goods
and services that people want need and
desire
and they either buy it or they don't
that has created
a standard of living that is the envy of
the world
well unimaginable in most places on this
earth
now warren is proposing let's talk about
stealing a brand new wealth tax
if you manage to save any money that's
after you pay your federal income taxes
your state income taxes your social
security tax your medicare tax sales tax
property tax in some cases like new york
city income tax
well then senator warren after you paid
all of that and you saved a little bit
she wants to come back again
and take more that would be a government
license to steal
senator and by the way then when you die
the federal government wants half of
what you save before you
you pay to die in america is that great
and states like new york take ten
percent of what you have left
and you got why are all these people
leaving new york new jersey illinois
california hundreds of thousands it's
the
mass exodus in these high tax states but
you look at states with low or no income
taxes take florida and texas no
state income tax nearly 400 000 new
residents
last year alone these people are leaving
just keep your bad politics wherever you
came from
of course the federal government will
need vast amounts of money like
look at kamala harris's medicare for all
proposals study george mason university
okay that's 3.2 trillion a year
for 10 years let me give you perspective
the federal budget 2018 was 4.1 trillion
basically the entire budget open your
wallets watch out
socialists like kamala are coming now
keep in mind
that proposal would literally kick 177
million americans off their private
health care plans
and also completely kill off another
private industry if you work for an
insurance company
bye-bye kamala harris wants you gone
jobless out of work
doesn't care by the way what happens
when medicare for all fails like
obamacare
uh oh what then now democrats are trying
to sell these big government programs
they are the great
uh they own compassion they're the most
compassionate
but don't be fooled a government power
grab plain and simple
this is what it's about don't trust they
don't trust you
they therefore want the government to
control every aspect of your life
they want to use your money i don't know
what it's really about to buy
votes bribe people to vote for them with
your money
and get power so let's recap the modern
day democratic party
the authoritarian control of your health
care your businesses your money and your
personal decisions
president trump put out a great tweet
today democrats are becoming the party
of late-term abortion high taxes open
borders and crime
and speaking of which we have an update
on that disturbing story out of virginia
from last night
democratic legislator there named kathy
tran proposed that bill that would make
infanticide legal
remember she testified her law would
allow a healthy baby's life to be
terminated for virtually any reason
even in the ninth month of pregnancy
even when
the birth process started and the
democratic governor ralph northam
supported the bill then he took it a
step further saying a baby's life
would only be saved it would be
comfortable it would be there
outside the womb but only saved
resuscitated if the family wanted and he
said
the infant would be resuscitated only
under those conditions
while the baby's alive viable
living comfortably seriously
after facing serious backlash well guess
what the great
governor of the commonwealth of virginia
did he doubled down on stupid
and even played the victim card we'll
show you those just
the disgusting comments coming up now
thankfully president trump is working
hard
doesn't get the credit from the media to
preserve core constitutional rights and
principles for all americans including
newly born children the most innocent
among us
top democrats are now seething with
anger over the president's
nomination of originalist justices many
doubters remember to
2016 you're worried i told you i knew
this man for over two decades and he
would govern as a conservative i think
i've been proven right and i told you so
as i warned you
obama was a rigid radical ideologue
whose policies would fail they did and
now president trump is fulfilling those
promises
we see the economic numbers we see more
peace around the world
we see him checking off the list of what
he said he'd do and now he's also
appointing strong qualified
justices so let not your heart be
troubled president trump will keep his
commitment
for those of you that doubt i say it's
99.9 percent to 0.1 percent
he's going to get the money for the wall
one way or the other and he announced
today
he's sending more troops down to the
border as
thousands and thousands of new migrants
in multiple caravans are marching
through mexico
right to our southern border yet again
one contains upward of 12 000 people
now what if they go to a point in our
border where there is
no secure wall or entry point
what is the border patrol going to do to
stop 12 000 people
they decided to rush across at once no
wall to stop them
i said that wall will protect people
rightly so on both sides of the wall and
have a nice store in it
so you know unfortunately take a little
more time we vet people make sure they
can provide for themselves
because the costs are out of control and
it isn't just the risks associated with
migraine
caravans so many instances of life and
death let's look at the
most recent week we have two previously
deported
sex offenders from mexico apprehended
trying to illegally enter the u.s
at the del rio sector in texas they were
caught on monday border patrol agents
apprehended
a violent ms-13 gang member thankfully
that person was caught
also on monday agents arrested a man who
was convicted of child molestation
in the u.s along with abducting and
kidnapping guess what they got
him too and just today u.s customs and
border protection announced
the single largest fentanyl bust in
history
our guys at the border the ones that
kamala harris said isn't there a
perception that
you know ice is like the kkk those guys
that risk their lives
well they captured over 250 pounds
of this deb deadly opioid inside a load
of
mexican produce heading to arizona now
just a stark reminder of just how many
deadly drugs come across that southern
border
destroying american lives especially
fentanyl
which is often used by drug dealers to
put into heroin
other addictive substances look at the
numbers 2016
fentanyl responsible for 46 percent of
all opioid opioid related deaths
it's a key reason that more than 42
thousand people dying from overdoses
involving opioids in 2016 that was an
increase in nearly 10 000 over the
previous year in fact
annual fentanyl related deaths have
dramatically increased since 2010
much of this coming from china and then
smuggled by the cartels through the
southern border by the way
enough to kill all the residents of
florida
pennsylvania utah and pick another state
54 million people that's how much they
got today
of fentanyl at our border millions of
people can be killed
which is why the president is pressing
the president of china
and he's getting results let's take a
look
one of the things that we discussed in
argentina was fentanyl
this is not a trade deal this is a fact
that uh president xi was extremely
good when he said that they would
criminalize fentanyl because fentanyl is
killing
a lot of our great american people
border security is about stopping these
evil cartels
the flow of drugs into the country in
other words it's about life and death
and saving the lives of american
citizens
hundreds dying every week from heroin
and fentanyl it's about stopping human
trafficking
it's about protecting people on both
sides of that wall
with the door and creating a safe secure
system of immigration
we get to vet anyone and everyone coming
into the country for our safety
and also make sure they are capable of
taking care of themselves
democrats they only want to play cheap
political games
rather than address a humanitarian
crisis a life and death
and safety and security crisis nancy
pelosi said again today
that funding for a wall is a non-starter
she offered a dollar so far take a look
there's not going to be any wall money
in in in the legislation
all about two things
cost benefit analysis what's the best
way
and what do you get for your dollar in
order to
protect the border what is nancy and
chuck and the democrats standing for
anyway
you know if they really cared about
cost-benefit analysis you'd be in favor
of the wall
we've done those numbers run them many
times on this show so why did democratic
leaders insist on obstructing
the president's efforts to keep
americans safe why do they insist on
derailing negotiations i thought they
cared about daca dreamers
and when obama was president they wanted
to buy a wall pay for a wall
why do they insist now on stopping their
rank and file members for
from coming to real solutions and
negotiating in good faith
only because they're consumed by
anti-trump hatred
every second every minute every hour of
every day
stop at nothing just destroy him for
years they supported everything
president trump
is offering they didn't mean it or they
hate him more they hate it more
that puts your community at risk your
friends at risk
your family at risk selling out dreamers
daca
that's all they seem to care about all
right we turn to another
brand new update from our hannity watch
on the deep state tonight it looks like
the hey trump media caught reporting yet
another collusion hoax yet again today
now remember when nearly every media
outlet
widely speculating donald trump jr
called his father with a block phone
number
ahead of his 2016 trump tower meeting
with the russians
when they talked about immigration and
adoption
now according to reports fake news never
happened
i just have one question for anyone who
works at fake news cnn
do you ever get tired of just being
wrong and embarrassing yourself
so often